So, we're now beginning at volume 17, and when we get to volume 18, we'll be halfway.
That's absolutely incredible.
It's just an amazingly long journey.
Okay.
So, volume 17, June the 10th, 1924.
One who lives in the divine will must enclose every thing.
Now, notice that this spirituality is universalist.
It's nothing to do with one individual, you must pray for all.
So, even if you are interceding for individuals, you must include everybody.
This morning, having received Holy Communion as usual, I was saying to my dear Jesus,
my sweet life, "I do not want to be alone while being with you, but I want everything
and everyone together with me.
Everything is all creation, and then everyone is all humanity.
And not only do I want all your children forming a circle around you, but I want the circle
of all things created by you, so that together with me in the endlessness of your most holy
will, in which I find everything, prostrate at your feet, all together, we may adore
you, thank you, and bless you."
Now, beside that, you'll have to put Romans 8, 19.
This is exactly what St. Paul says that the whole of creation is crying out for, is that
the speaking creation, which is us, will take the mute creation, which is all around us,
and take everything to the foot of the Lord.
We're the speaking creation.
And that we all together, we take absolutely everything, all human beings, and all the
creation that cannot speak.
In the meantime, I could see all created things, though running to form a circle around Jesus,
so that each one of them might pay its homage to Him.
I added, "See my love, how beautiful your works are."
Now, she usually does the sun, moon, stars, and water, they're her favorites.
How the sun, breaching with its rays, while prostrating to adore you, rises up to you
to embrace you, and to kiss you.
How the stars forming a crown around you, smile at you with their sweet twinkling and
say to you, "You are great."
I turned that into English, is that okay?
We give you glory forever and ever.
How the sea runs with its harmonious murmuring, like many silvery voices, and it says to you
infinite thanks to our Creator.
But the one who says the words is the speaking creation, it's us, we're saying it on behalf
of all.
And I, together with the sun, embrace you and kiss you with the stars, I recognize you
and glorify you with the sea, I thank you.
But who can say everything I was saying, calling all created things around Jesus?
It seems to me that each created thing had a distinct office to be able to pay its homage
to its Creator.
Now, while I was doing this, I thought to myself that I was wasting time, and this was
not the thanksgiving to be given to Jesus after communion, so she thought it needed to
be something much more apparently pious than this.
I said to Jesus, "But he was all goodness to me," and he said, "My daughter, my will
contains everything.
And one who lives in it must let nothing escape her of all the things that belong to me."
Even more, if only one thing escapes her, it's enough to say that she does not give
me all the honor and the glory which my will contains.
Now, we need to remember that, that even if you're praying for an individual or one situation,
that you must include everything and everyone, otherwise you don't give him all the honor
and all the glory that he wants.
Therefore, it cannot be said that her life is complete in the divine will, nor does she
give me the requital of all that my will has given to her.
In fact, I have given everything to one who lives in my will.
Please note and color it if you color your text.
I give everything.
Therefore, we have all responsibility as well.
Would a hand lens help you?
If you're going to, this study should be under, I've only taught of it now.
So, I have given everything to one who lives in my will, and I go to her as though in triumph
upon the wings of my works, to give her the new requital of my love, and she must come
along the same path as mine, and give me the new requital of her love.
So, this is reciprocal love, okay?
Would it not be delightful for you if you had made many beautiful and various works,
and someone whom you love placed them around you to please you, and showing them one by
one said to you, see, these are your works, how beautiful this one is, how artistic is
this other one, and this third one, what great mastery, and in this fourth one, what a variety
of colors.
So, this is your rounds of creation, okay?
What enchantment in this other one?
What joy would in our field?
What glory for you?
That's the way it is for me.
Or so, since having to centralize everything within the soul who lives in my will, one
who lives in my will must be like the heartbeat of creation.
Now, not only are we the speaking creation, but we're actually the expression of love
in creation, the heartbeat, in such a way that as all things palpitate within her by virtue
of my will, she must form them into one single heartbeat, to return to me.
In that heartbeat, the heartbeats of everyone and everything, and to bring me back the glory
and the love of all things which came out from me.
So, everything came out to us in love and through love, and everything must go back
to him in love and through love, because God is love, and the circle of creation and redemption
and sanctification is the circle of love.
He said, "I must find everyone in the soul in whom my will reigns, so that containing
everything she may give me all that the others should give me."
Now, that's one of our big duties in the divine will, is to give him the glory others
don't give, to give him the love, the thanksgiving, the praise, the blessing, and everything
that others don't give.
Now, in the next section, I want you to put a heading here.
Living in the divine will is different from all other sanctities, or if you just want
to put different sanctity just to alert yourself to the fact that this paragraph is actually
terribly important.
My daughter, the living in my will is very different from the other sanctities.
Now, the other sanctities include all the canonized saints, every one of them, okay?
And this is why, until now, that is the revelation of the divine will, the way and the true teachings
of living in the divine will cannot be found.
Now, please note that you'll need to know where the reference is when someone asks
you, okay, the revelation of the divine will was not found before Louisa.
It can be said that the other sanctities are the shadows of the divine life.
Now, to know the enormity of that statement, if you've read the works of John of the Cross,
which are utterly exalted, and to find that Jesus said that even all that John is expressing
is only a shadow of the divine will.
We might somehow begin to touch the enormity of what the Lord is offering to you and me.
It's really incredible.
These other sanctities are the shadows of my divine life, while my will is the source.
He's brought us right back to the source, which, of course, is God Himself in the Holy
Trinity.
Therefore, be attentive in the exercises of living in my divine will, be attentive to
living and fusing and acting in the divine will, so that from you may come the true way
and the exact and precise teachings, that's what we're getting in these volumes, so that
those who want to live in the divine will may find not the shadow, but the true sanctity
of the divine life on earth, isn't it something else?
Furthermore, since my humanity on earth was in my divine will, there was not a work, a
thought, a word, or anything else, which was not enclosed in me so as to cover all the
works of creatures, and that's what He wants us to do as well in all our praise and thanksgiving
our rounds and everything is our covering everybody and we're saying, look, treat them
as if they're all doing it because I'm speaking in your divine will in their name, and that's
why everything must be utterly universal with us.
It can be said that I had a thought for each thought, a word for each word, and so with
all the rest, to glorify my father completely and to give light, life, goods, and remedies
to creatures.
Now, I want to give you a text in the Old Testament that you know, probably off by heart, but
in this context it takes on a completely new light and that's Habakkuk 214, Habakkuk, H-A-B-B,
and he says that the country will be filled with the knowledge of the Lord as the waters
cover the sea.
It's only in the divine will that that reaches a height that even the writer himself couldn't
have touched.
And this is the wonderful thing about the Bible is that very often the writer himself
doesn't know the full extent of what God is actually saying, it's absolutely brilliant.
Okay.
So that's Habakkuk 214, for the country will be filled with the knowledge of the Lord as
the waters cover the sea.
Now, everything exists in my will, and you need to remember that when you're looking
for anything from God, everything is in his will.
And one who must live in it must enclose all creatures, will you circle the must?
This is the universal part of our mission.
So as to go through all my acts again and place on them another beautiful divine shade
taken from my will to give me the requital of what I did.
Now, he wants each one of us in the divine will to enclose all creatures and to go through
all his acts again and to place on them another beautiful divine shade.
So I've been trying to say this to you for quite some time that if all of us here in
this room are doing this, he will get different shades because we're coming at it from different
angles.
We won't do it the same way unless somebody says A, B, C, D, and A. And therefore he will
be able to pull new shades out of his divine will because you're pulling this one and somebody
else is pulling that one and he gets this wonderful response from us all.
That's why it's so important for us to let the individual response come out.
So you must enclose all creatures and go through all my acts again and place on them
another beautiful divine shade taken from my will because everything's there and to give
me the requital of what I did.
Only one who lives in my will can give me this requital, would you circle the can?
Only one who lives in the divine can do it.
And I await her as the means to be able to place the divine will in communication with
the human so the Lord is waiting for you and me to use us as the means to communicate
with everybody.
Isn't that something else?
Just like saying you have a mobile phone and it's your means to communicate with everybody.
He wants to use us as the means to communicate with everybody.
So what is the communication he wants to do?
It's to put the divine will in communication with the human will because it's the human
will that must surrender.
And to give her, that's the soul, all the goods that the divine will contains.
I want the creature as the intermediary.
Not just Louisa, each one of us.
So that's your Sam 106, 23, you stand in the breach for all humanity.
Sam 106 verse 23, you stand in the breach for all humanity.
I want the creature as an intermediary who going through the same path which my humanity
covered in my will may open the door of the kingdom of my will.
So in doing all this intercession that we do, in the name of all, we're actually opening
the door for the return of Christ and glory.
It's terribly important.
Now Greg's way of saying that is that we're knitting the red carpet for his return.
It's a lovely way of saying it.
Now if I could widen that a little bit, everything that the occult is doing today is opening
the door for the return of the Antichrist.
Everything that the atheists and all the people living in moral lives are doing is opening
the door for the return of evil.
What we're doing is opening the door for the return of Christ and the divine will to the
earth and therefore the kingdom of God and the fulfillment of the scriptures.
And therefore you can see that this is a mighty conflict, absolutely mighty.
So those in the divine will may open the door of the kingdom of my will which has been closed
by the human will and that's by rebellion against God's will.
Therefore your mission is great and it takes sacrifice and great attention.
So Teresa said I was feeling immersed in the divine volition and Jesus continued.
My daughter, my will is everything, circle there is.
In other words, this is the only issue for us and my will contains everything.
It contains everything you need and everybody else's needs as well.
And then it is the beginning, it's the means and it is the end of the human race.
Beginning means and end.
Okay.
Now if you know the scriptures, the Old Testament scriptures particularly well enough, you will
know that the only issue in the Old Testament scriptures is the will of God.
Okay, if you take Sam 50 as an example, the Lord said I never told you to sacrifice all
those animals, I want them alive on my mountains, I only asked you to do my will, okay.
So this is why in creating man, I did not give him any law.
Why would God not give Adam a law?
It's because Adam was in communion with the divine will.
He was in union with God, therefore he was above law.
You only give law to somebody who needs to be curtailed in some way.
Or did I institute sacraments, which is not necessary, there's only Adam around, okay.
But I gave him my will alone, that's all we need.
And therefore when you are living in the divine will, you're living higher than the law, you're
living higher than everything else because as he would find himself in the beginning
of the divine will, it would be more than sufficient so that he might find all the means to reach
not a low sanctity but the height of the divine sanctity.
Now when this text uses the word height, it means summit.
We would say the summit of a mountain.
We use height in a slightly different context because height can be any height.
What they actually mean is the summit.
And therefore he would find himself in the port of his end, that's as awkward as it gets,
you would find yourself in the harbor of your destiny, in other words the ship is already
arriving in the harbor, okay, the harbor of your destiny.
So this means that man was to need nothing but my will alone.
That's as clear as daylight, isn't it?
And in my will, he was to find everything in a surprising, admirable and easy way.
I want to say, even though many talks you have heard in divine will may give a different
impression that everything in the divine will is easy.
It's actually not complicated and prayers in the divine will are simple, short, easy.
So we must make sure we don't multiply them unnecessarily.
So he was to find everything in a surprising admirable and easy way to render himself wholly
and happy in time and in eternity because he was living a heavenly life on earth.
So going to heaven was not going to be a problem.
Now if I gave him a law after centuries and centuries of creation, now what the Lord means
there is that it was the 13th century before Christ before a law was given.
That's the time of Moses and that's the covenant on Sinai's 13th century before Christ.
I have to say approximately because nobody knows the actual date.
So if I did give him a law after centuries and centuries of creation, it was because
man had lost his beginning.
In other words, the human race was now a fallen race.
And therefore he had lost the means and the end.
He had lost his way.
So the law was not the beginning.
It was only the means, whereas the divine will is the beginning, the means and the end.
It's everything.
But in seeing that with my law, now when you see the words my law and even when you see
it in the scriptures, it means the word of God.
It's God's word.
So with my word, man was still getting lost and we have that situation today.
In coming upon the earth, I instituted the sacraments as stronger and more powerful means
to save him.
Now here's your reply to the Protestant churches.
It's not the word of God versus the sacraments.
It's not the word or the Eucharist, it's both and.
Okay.
So I instituted the sacraments as stronger and more powerful means to save him.
But how many abuses and how many prophonations do we not have in the sacraments?
How many use the law and the very sacraments to sin more and to fall into hell while with
my will alone, which is the beginning, the means and the end, the soul places herself
in safety.
That means spiritual safety.
She rises to divine sanctity and she reaches in a complete way the purpose for which she
was created.
Isn't that wonderful?
Now let me put this with the thought of persecution ahead of us.
Okay.
They can take the church buildings away from us.
They can take the sacraments away.
They can take the priests away.
They did that in Russia, didn't they?
Okay.
They can take the mass away, they can't take the divine will away.
And what the Lord is telling us in these writings is that in a situation of persecution,
the people in the divine will have everything and they're the ones to gather the others.
Now do you get it, that when we realize that everything is in the divine will, that when
the others are taken from us, the divine will has everything and that's very, very important.
Some people in America in the early days back in the 90s misunderstood this and said, you
know, if everything is in the divine will, we don't need to go to mass, you know, and
we don't need the sacraments and they just misunderstood.
It's in a time of persecution when everything would be taken away, you would still have
everything if you're in the divine will because you yourself become a living host to see.
So and Jesus said, and there's not a shadow of danger that she might offend me because
if you're living on this divine level, sin is on a planet in a galacty far away.
We've left that in volume one, we're in volume 17.
So sin doesn't come into this at all, okay, you could put one John three to there.
Those who are in divine union don't sin, okay.
So the safest place is only in my will.
The very sacraments if they're not received in order, we would say correctly with the
right dispositions with my will can serve as means of condemnation and ruin.
That's 1 Corinthians 11 verses 29 to 30 that those who don't recognize the body and blood
of the Lord can eat and drink to their own condemnation.
This is why I inculcate my will so much because the soul being in her beginning, that means
you go back to the state of innocence, okay.
The means will be favorable to her and she will receive the fruits that they contain.
On the other hand, without the divine will, the sacraments themselves may be a poison
for her because you could be coming with wrong dispositions and abusing the sacraments and
so on and they may lead her to eternal death.
It's a very good instruction there, isn't it?
So June the 14th, we're talking about the order that's in the writings of Louisa and
when I'm reading it, I want you to think that we're all being called into divine order.
Not only everything inside of me as an individual, but my relationships with others have got
to be in divine order, my work has got to be in divine order, everything has got to
be in divine order and the Lord is very strong about this.
This morning while I was in my usual state, I don't know whether it was a dream, she said,
but I saw my late confessor, that's Father Gennaro D. Gennaro, is the name down in your
book?
Is it down at the end?
Anyway, you can put it on your page, now Father Gennaro had been her spiritual director
for many, many years, okay, so at this particular stage, there's at least three of our spiritual
directors dead, okay, and he seemed to take something twisted from within my mind, so he's
on the other side now, and I'll ask you a question and I won't answer it, is he in heaven?
Or where is he?
So he seemed to take something twisted from within my mind, and he fixed it and he untied
it, so he's organizing something inside of her head, I asked him why he was doing that
and he said to me, "I've come to tell you to be attentive to order."
Very interesting, because God is order, and if just one sentence, one word of what the
Lord tells you is not in order, it might be enough to cause doubts and difficulties in
those who will read it, what you write and is adorable will.
If you go back to Bernadette of Lords, for example, she was given a message from heaven,
"I am the Immaculate Conception," no matter what pressure they put under her, she never
changed the words, she just said, "This is what I was told," she didn't try to explain
it, nothing else, she just gave the words, and she gave them in the order that she received
them, she didn't understand what she was saying, but she gave them, and she didn't know she
was giving an answer to the Pope that he had asked heaven for a confirmation.
If you want to listen to someone who's had an authentic encounter with God, that person
will tell you exactly what happened, and even if the story is told ten times, you'll hear
the same exact words.
Have you noticed that?
That's very important, because that's one of the ways that you discern that something
is from God, and so here Louisa is being told that even her deciding to put it slightly
differently to what she actually heard is interference, because that's the human mind
interfering with the divine.
On hearing this, Louisa said, "Do you perhaps know that I've written disordered things up
to now?"
And the Confessors said, "No, no, but be attentive in the future," he's being delicate,
isn't he?
"Let the things you're right be clear," watch that now, "simple," those speaking in
dram and chain, please take note, "clear," "simple," "no complications," and Jesus
said, "Omit, nothing," because if one little sentence, one word of those which Jesus tells
you is missing, or if you write it differently, you see, that's the human mind getting involved,
it's enough for order to be lacking.
Isn't that interesting?
In fact, those words will serve to give light, to make things be understood with more clarity,
and to link the order of the truths which good Jesus manifests to you.
So Louisa was obviously not being sufficiently careful to realize that if Jesus gave that
little illustration, it was going to connect things where people studying this would see
the connections, she doesn't see them, and so she had to be very careful what she writes.
Watch this, you are apt to omit many little things.
Now you've heard that since Volume 1, while the little things link the great.
You know if you get a beautiful bokeh of red, red, red roses which I love, but you can't
have them without the lovely little white, tiny little plants that show them off.
The red roses, no matter how exotic they are, they need these tiny little things to show
them off, otherwise, you don't actually see the glory that's actually there.
That's what Jesus is saying, the little ones show off the great.
Now notice in dramatine it's going to be all little ones, okay.
They link the great and the great link the little.
Therefore be attentive in the future that everything may be orderly.
Having said this, he disappeared and I remained a little bit concerned.
She said, because she knew she was being ticked off.
After this I was abandoning all of myself, so that's me fusing all of me in all of you
Lord all the time, okay.
I do divine will prayers very quick.
I don't spend hours at divine will prayers, I'm fusing all of me in all of you all the
time and get on with it, okay.
I was abandoning all of myself in the holy divine will of my Jesus and my Jesus moving
in my interior told me, my daughter how beautiful it is to see a soul operate in my will.
She plunges her action, her thought, her word into my will and she's like a sponge and as
she impregnates herself with all the goods which the supreme volition contains many divine
acts can be seen in the soul which spread light.
Now there's your Matthew 514, let your light shine so that everybody will see and they will
give glory to the Father, okay.
So as we're plunging in the divine will this wonderful light comes and this light is God
manifesting and it almost cannot cannot be distinguished which are the acts of the creator
or the creature because they're one, okay.
That's like saying I take two half glasses of water and I mix them together, who knows
which one was in which thing first because they're now one, you can't separate them.
So being impregnated with this eternal will these acts have absorbed within themselves
a power, a light and the way of operating of the eternal majesty so they are divine.
Look at yourself how beautiful my will has made you not only this but in each one of
your acts I enclose myself.
If you were going to multiply acts for no other reason you do it for that wouldn't you?
I enclose myself because by enclosing my will you enclose everything.
So Louisa said she looked at herself and oh how much light came out with what struck
her and pleased her the most was to see that Jesus enclosed in each, Jesus was enclosed
in each one of her acts.
His will imprisoned him within Louisa as in a tabernacle, I think that's fantastic.
So one Corinthians 3 16, no you not that you are the temple of the living God, it's wonderful.
And it's real, this isn't just pious talk, do you know what I mean?
This is real reality.
And so June the 20th, 1924 the divine will renders both God and the soul happy, that's
not bad now.
As I was in my usual state I found myself outside of myself together with my most sweet Jesus.
And he was all goodness and all admirable.
He took my hands in his and he pressed them tightly to his breast and all love he told
me, my beloved daughter, if you knew what pleasure, what delight I feel in speaking
to you about my will.
Each additional thing that I manifest to you on my will is one more happiness that I release
from myself and communicate to the soul.
Every single thing is another happiness.
And I feel that I am made happier in this soul by virtue of my own happiness.
In fact the distinctive speciality of my will is precisely this to render God and man happy.
Because God is love, God is unity, God is light, God is order and therefore all of that coming
into us just to give you a tiny example renders us happy, okay.
I want to give you John 13 17.
Don't you remember my daughter, how much we delighted together, I am speaking to you
and you in listening to me and how we made one another happy.
Now there are so many references for that, I'm just simply going to say to you the dialogues
in the song of songs.
So the bridegroom delights in the bride and the bride delights in the bridegroom.
It's all over the song of songs and that's what he's referring to.
Of course you'll find these dialogues of delight, you'll find them mostly in volumes
one to three, okay so you might put volume one to three there as well so that you'll
have a volume reference as well.
And since my will alone contains the seed of happiness, we, I by manifesting it and the
soul by knowing it, form the plant and the fruits of everlasting and eternal true happiness
notice the word everlasting.
It's not ephemeral.
When the world offers you happiness it's only for the night you're out or the holiday
you're on or whatever and this true happiness never ceases.
And not only us but those who listen to or read the admirable and surprising things of
my will also feel the sweet enchantment of my happiness.
I think that's the first time you're told that if you even read the stuff it's communicated
to you.
Isn't that fantastic?
Therefore in order to make myself happy in my works I want to speak to you of the nobility
of my will.
You see he's trying to tell us that if we really grasp what the divine will is about
it actually adds a nobility to that person.
Like when you meet someone who's really holy, there's an automatic respect for that person.
I want to tell you about the nobility of my will, of where the soul can reach and of
what she must enclose if she lets my will enter into herself.
The nobility of my will is divine.
And since it is from heaven it does not descend into one in whom it finds, sorry, it does
not descend but into one in whom it finds a noble courtage.
Therefore the first one to let the divine will enter was my humanity.
I want to give you John 5.30 there and John 8.29.
My will was not content with little.
It wants everything because it wants to give everything.
So it wants everything from us in order to be able to give everything.
So if the Lord is to give everything he wants to me, I have to make enough room for that
gift.
So my last has got to empty in order to be filled.
But all the saints knew that anyway.
I mean, St. Therese of Lisieux used to say that we go to God with empty hands every day.
And how can the divine will give everything if it does not find everything so as to be
able to place all of its goods in it?
So my humanity gave to the divine will the holy and noble courtage.
That's the retinue of virtues that is required.
And my will centralized everything and everyone in me.
So I want to give you Colossians 1.16, the second half of the verse.
So you're right.
Be there.
Colossians 1.16, be a lowercase, be a lowercase, be a second half of the verse.
So I want to give you a heading for the next long section, the privilege of intimacy with
the most holy Trinity.
See then how in order for my will to come and reign in the soul, she must enclose within
herself all that my humanity did.
It's all for all.
And if the other creatures have shared in part in the fruits of my redemption, according
to their dispositions, that's the saints up to now, this creature will centralize them
all within herself in order to form the noble courtage of my will.
And my will will centralize in the soul the love which it gives to and wants from all.
Now try and take that on board.
He will centralize in you everything he wants to give to everybody else and everything he
wants to receive from everybody else.
I mean it's mind buckling isn't it?
I mean you can understand the English words but to take on the reality is a different subject.
So my will will centralize in the soul the love which it gives to and wants from all
souls in order to be able to receive the love of all and of each one from that person.
That's why all our prayers in the divine will have got to be universal.
Or the way I used to put it in the past was all the prayers have to be PPF past present
and future.
It's not the divine will is not content with finding in the soul the requital of her own
love only so the me me me you left it behind back in volume one you dropped it that's gone.
We're not just representing ourselves we're representing the whole of humanity from Adam
to Zachary I call it A to Z.
It wants the requital of everything in the soul in whom the divine will wants to reign.
My will wants to find all the relations which exist in creation between creation and creation
and creature there's your rounds otherwise its happiness would not be full nor would
it find all its things and the whole of itself.
In the soul in whom it reigns my will must be able to say if no one loved me and requited
me I am happy on my own no one can set in my happiness because in her I find everything.
Here's the the value of one in the kingdom of God and and how much the Lord prizes each
person who attempts to try and live this life for him.
Because in her I find everything I receive everything and I can give everything and in
the soul who lives in the divine will he has a throne on earth.
It would repeat the sentence which is in the three divine persons we are untouchable.
As much as creatures might do no one can touch us not even slightly shade our eternal and
immutable happiness only one who possesses our will can touch us can enter to form one
thing with us because since she is happy with the divine and eternal happiness which is
our own happiness.
In other words the only one who can really touch the most holy Trinity is somebody who
is living in the divine will therefore you're living in the heart of the Trinity.
And therefore that person's happiness is their happiness which is divine eternal perfect
and untouchable is that fantastic.
So it doesn't matter what storms you have on the outside it's what's going on on the
inside that's terribly important.
So we the blessed Trinity remain glorified from the happiness of the creature only when
my will reigns in a complete way in creatures then will charity reach complete perfection
in the creature now notice that only the divine will can actually bring the virtue of charity
to its completion and if you remember one Corinthians 13 13 love is the greatest thing
in the end there's faith hope and love but the greatest of these is love and then he
goes on in one Corinthians 14 one you must want love more than anything else you know
what I mean so if love comes to perfection in us now you'd have to go right into all
of St. John's letters and everything if love comes to perfection in us we have reached
the destiny because God is love okay so he says that love or charity now when they use
the word charity they mean agape they mean divine love so when divine love reaches perfection
in the creature sorry it's only when the divine will reigns in a complete way that divine love
reaches perfection I'll say it right yet so that's one John for seven and following
because God is love because then the by virtue of my will each one will find herself in each
creature loved defended and sustained so therefore if someone reaches the fullness of love every
soul that has ever lived will be loved defended sustained helped blessed prayed for and have
the precious blood Jesus put on them all it's absolutely incredible so you get an extraordinary
harmony in creation each one will find herself transfused within the other as in one's own
life now there's your John 13 34 you must love one another in the same way as I loved
you that's in a divine manner in the same way and John 15 9 as the father loved me I love
you the father loved Jesus infinitely absolutely eternally unconditionally knowing everything
about his son and the son loves us absolutely eternally unconditionally knowing everything
about us okay that's terribly important so each one will find yourself transfused within
the other as one's own life that's like saying that you have now put these two glasses of
water but now it's two human beings and they can be completely one as well because both
of them are one in the divine will so you'll get this extraordinary healing of the body
of Christ then with all the virtues then will all the virtues reach complete perfection because
they will not not be nourished by human life but by divine life everything will have reached
the level that the Lord actually wants therefore I need two humanities one is Jesus the others
Louisa my own in order to form the redemption and another one that's Louisa to form the
fiat volunteers to unearth as it is in heaven one more necessary than the other because if
in the first one I was to come and redeem man in the second one which is Louisa I was
to come to restore humanity to the only purpose for which he was created that is to open the
current of graces between the human will and the divine and to make the divine reign on
earth as it is in heaven so the kingdom of God I'll give you Luke 17 21 and John 1836
just as my humanity in order to redeem man let my will reign on earth as it does in heaven
so do I keep looking for another humanity which letting the divine will reign on earth
as it does in heaven may allow me accomplish all my designs in creation that's one of the
things I keep asking him for that he will take I usually make it as my prayer at the
assumption decade of the rosary because blessed mother experienced the fullness of redemption
and I ask him by virtue of his divine will that he would take as many as possible into
the deepest depths of the divine will so that all his plans for humanity will be completed
because his plans for redemption were completed because Mary was completely surrendered to
the divine will and so I ask him to take as many as possible there so that all his plans
for humanity will be completed so it's a way of praying for the redemption sanctification
and glorification of the whole of humanity and again look it didn't take me 30 seconds
to say it to me divine will prayers are quick therefore be attentive in letting my will alone
reign in you and I will love you with the same love with which I loved my own humanity Ephesians
3 19 John 15 12 and Matthew 19 19 so John 15 12 and Matthew 19 19 is that okay now July
the first gives us another way to really really intercede for the human race the blood of
Jesus is the defense of creatures before the rights of divine justice so you have to make
sure that every single day you bathe the whole human race and all the souls and purgatory
in the precious blood of the lamb after you fuse of course I felt very oppressed because
of the privation of my adorable Jesus oh how my heart bleeds and I find I feel subjected
to suffer continuous death I felt I could take no more without him and that my martyrdom
could not be harder and while I was trying to follow Jesus in the different mysteries
of his passion notice trying if you underline that she doesn't always succeed I don't know
if you do and she was trying to follow Jesus in the different mysteries of his passion
I came to accompany him in the mystery of his painful scourging at that moment he moved
in my interior filled me filled all of me with his adorable person on seeing him I wanted
to tell him about my heart state but Jesus imposed silence on me because it's all about
him it's not about us okay you need to just remind yourself about that it's all about
him it's all about him not us okay it's a very important thing to keep reminding ourselves
because we might be want likely ways of wanting to tell them all our little troubles and stuff
forget about it he said my daughter let us pray together there are certain sad times
in which my justice unable to contain itself because of the evils of humanity would want
to flood the earth with new scourges now notice flood doesn't nothing to do with water and
so the prayer in my will is necessary which extending over all places itself as defense
of creatures notice the prayer in the divine will so that's Sam 106 verse 23 is stand in
the breach so prayer in my will is necessary because extending over all it places itself
as defense of creatures and with its power it prevents my justice from getting close to
the creature in order to strike her so now we have a lovely prayer of Jesus giving us
the template as to what to do okay how beautiful and touching it was to hear Jesus pray and
since I was accompanying him in the sorrowful mystery of his scourging he made himself seen
deluging blood and I heard him say this is Jesus praying during the scourging my father
I offer you this blood of mine oh please let it cover all the intelligences of creatures
or please pray this rendering all their evil thoughts vain dampening the fire of their
passions and making holy intelligences rise again may this blood of mine cover their eyes
and be availed to their sight so that the taste for evil pleasures may not enter into
them and they may not dirty themselves with the mud of the earth mud of the earth is usually
fleshly sins made this blood of mine cover and fill their mouths and render their lips
dead to blasphemies to imprecations and to all bad words we'd have quite a change in
our society wouldn't we my father made this blood of mine cover their hands and strike
in them terror for so many wicked actions made this blood circulate in our will to cover
all to defend and to be a defending weapon for creatures before the rights of divine
justice isn't that a magnificent prayer because it's actually covering the whole of the person
and all the ways that we can go around and then she said but who can say how Jesus prayed
and everything he said she doesn't get it does she she's been told not to leave anything
out and what did she do she stops in the middle of it I know I do the same do you how often
do you have to be told to do something then afterwards Jesus kept silent and in my interior
I felt Jesus taking my little and poor soul in his hands squeezing it touching it up looking
at his well Monday morning he's cleaning up Ephesians 210 where God's work of art so
the artist is touching up the picture my love what are you doing now notice even at the
extraordinary height that she's at in her relationship with God she still needs that
dusting down and that touching up so the cleansing and purification is never going to stop for
us I mean I don't know if you think you're in the place she's in but she's at least 35,000
miles above me okay and so if she needs this then I need it on a daily basis okay this is
just being realistic yeah so is there anything in me that displeases you she said my love
he said ashram working away and expanding your soul in my will now I think that's fantastic
because in order to be able to get more grace and the ability to operate more deeply in the
divine will he has to actually increase our capacity because we don't have the capacity
and besides he said I do not have to give you an account of what I do why is that she's
so on he's she's all his he owns her not only did he create her and redeemer but she has
surrendered herself as well okay because having given yourself completely to me you've lost
the rights all the rights are mine now we're grand until somebody says that isn't that right
then you realize that you're not so sure about this complete surrender do you know what is
your only right it is that my will be yours isn't that incredible and that is administer
to you everything that will make you happy in time and in eternity so this is called at
the possession of God you own him he owns you is now unbelievable okay so july the 16th
we have the perennial problem of the creator going in search of the creature is the shepherd
looking for his sheep okay Adam where are you do you remember in Genesis chapter 3 can't
remember it's around verse 8 Adam where are you maybe it might be 18 do you know what
I mean oh absolutely yeah it's the Lord searching for the soul continuing in my usual state my
adorable Jesus transported me outside of myself and told me my daughter the creator goes in
search of the creature I want to give you just a few references I could give you most of the
Bible but I won't John 10 the shepherd goes looking for a sheep Sam 23 Luke 24 13 to 25 as Jesus
looking for the apostles after the resurrection Sam Luke 24 verses 13 to 25 acts chapter 8 from
verse 26 to 40 as the shepherd looking for his sheep and you have the two disciples on the road
to Emmaus to remember as well or that's the Luke 24 sorry that's the Luke 24 and it's the two
disciples and the road to Emmaus okay as so he goes and started the creature in order to place on
her lap the goods that he issued in creation now the Lord seeks us to give not to take this is why
in all centuries the Lord always disposes that there be souls who go in search of him alone now
this is what is what keeps the church alive that in every generation he gives special grace to a
certain number of souls to really go seeking him and those souls can then go helping others to seek
and find him okay so I love that guaranteeing the church staying alive he always disposes that
there be souls who go in search of him alone so that he may place his goods in those who search
for him so if you search for him he's going to give a different gifts to different people and that
will keep the church alive those who search for him and they want to receive his gifts so the creator
moves from heaven and the creature moves from the earth in order to meet now that's Sam 85 verses 10
to 13 the one from heaven moves to give and the one from earth to receive Jesus said that God feels
all the necessity to give because love lives by giving to prepare goods in order to give them
and to have no one to whom to receive them keeping them idle because of a lack of response on the
part of those who don't care about receiving them that's always a great pain okay but do you know
in whom I can place the goods which came out of me in creation I can place them in one who makes
my will her own because he's much more free in that person because the divine will alone gives
her the capacity now notice see we don't have the capacity by ourselves gives the soul the capacity
the appreciation you see this the study of these writings helps us to have the appreciation of the
gift and the true dispositions in order to receive the goods of our creation see if you're not
properly disposed you won't be able to receive anyway and administers to her the requital the
gratitude and the thanksgiving and the love which she is obliged to give for the gifts which from
so much goodness she has received so the Lord not only in these writings not only disposed us to
receive what tells us exactly how we should respond as well you know that's like a parent saying to
a child what do you say next thank you and if they don't say thank you you put the words on their
lips don't you yeah well that's the way it used to be we're living in abnormality at the moment
and therefore come with me Jesus said and let us go around together throughout the earth and the
heavens that I may place in you the love which I issued for the love of creatures in all created
things and so that you may give me the requital of them this is the speaking creation that we
give him the thanksgiving and praise and glory for all the mute creation and together with me you
may love everyone with my love so he enables us to love with this divine love with agape love we're
only able to love with the natural love do you remember that incident at the the sea after the
resurrection when Jesus said to Peter Peter Simon son of John he said do you agape me I'm giving you
the original word there he said no Lord I fill us you fill us p-h-i-l-u-s now fill us is the love of
a disciple for his master or it's the love of a friend for a friend whereas agape is divine love
and Peter with the remembrance the sickening remembrance of his denial couldn't say he loved
Jesus with divine love no way what he did say I love you with the disciples love so Jesus repeated
do you agape me no I fill us you and in the end Jesus said do you fill us me and he said yeah I do
it's actually sad Jesus had to come down to this human level and that the human level that he could
meet Peter at that point Peter could not meet him up with the higher level Peter had too much
repentance to go through you know and it's important that to have that dialogue because
that dialogue has to happen in us as well and that we have to be really honest about it Lord at this
particular moment I'm not even sure I'm a friend of yours you know don't have you ever been there have
you okay and I'm not sure I'm not sure I could tell you I could love you either you know I'm
feeling a bit angry with you because of blah blah blah you've got to be really honest with him
and if you're honest you'll get there but if you pretend of course you'll not get anywhere pretending
with the Lord is absolute unbelievable unforgivable folly okay because he reads it anyway and he knows
exactly why you're pretending so it's very important
so if the Lord wants to ask us do you agape me you have to find out how do you respond to that
you don't have to go back to Peter's position you just say to him if you want me to agape you
I'm open you can give it to me and then I'll give it to you but there's nothing in me
without you I can do nothing John 15 5 so if you want me to love at this level you have to give me
this love and then I will love you with it okay so the creator comes down from heaven and the
creature moves from the earth in order to meet one to give and the other to receive I feel all the
necessity to give Jesus said to prepare goods in order to give them and to have no one to receive
them is terrible pain okay but I get the person who can receive it he said is the one who makes my
will her own because the divine will alone gives her the capacity here we are at it again the
appreciation and the true dispositions in order to receive the goods of her creator and the divine
will alone administers to her the requital the gratitude the thanksgiving and the love which
he's supposed to give so the Lord gives us everything all you got to do is really open up
so my comment at the side there is just simply open up you don't have to have profound theology
just open up and he'll give it to you anyway do you expect an infant at the breast to understand
the quality of milk they're receiving or anything else that you give them no you only expect them
to open them out and receive it and they'll they'll grow anyway isn't that right so with things we
don't understand don't waste your head trying to get to understand it just open your soul receive
it and then he'll give you understanding because the child will eventually come to understand it
therefore come with me he said let's go around together throughout the whole earth and the
heavens that I may place in you the love which I issued for love of creatures in all created things
so that you may give me the requital for them and together with me you may love everyone with
my love now he'll give it to you you just have to open up we will give love to all that is all
the inanimate creation all animate creation and all humanity we will be too in loving everyone
now that is Matthew 1819 I think it is if two of you agree concerning any matter I will ratify
it in heaven okay there'll be two of us doing it and so if there's two of us doing it it's going
to be very powerful and we will give love to all we will be too in loving everyone I will no longer
be alone so Louisa said we wandered everywhere and Jesus placed in me his love which created
things contained and I echoing his love because that's all we can do repeated with him the I love
you of all creatures so you do it through him with him and in him then afterwards Jesus added my
daughter in creating man I infused the soul into him with my breath now my breath is Ruach Adonai
or you A.C.H. or you A.C.H. is Ruach and A.D.O.N.I that is the spirit of God the breath of God
so that's Genesis 2 7 okay wanting to infuse in him the inmost part of our interior which was
our will that's why Genesis says he became a living being of course he was alive before
but this is living spiritually not just physically so we wanted to give him our will which would
also bring him all the particles of our divinity which as a creature he could not contain to the
extent of making of him our image Genesis 1 27 and Romans 8 29 but man was ungrateful and he wanted
to break off from our will and even though he still had his soul the human will which took the
place of the divine obscured him infected him and rendered all the divine particles idle to the
extent of disordering him completely and of maiming him now that's as clear as daylight isn't it
now since I want to dispose him again to receive this will of mine it's necessary that I return
to breeze on him again that's the prophet Joel chapter three verses one to five the holy spirit
will be poured upon all flesh so that my breath may put to flight the darkness and the infections
from him and may render active the particles of our divinity which we infused in him in creating
him oh how I wish to see him beautiful restored just as I created him and my will alone can work
this great tragedy so this is the new Pentecost we're talking about this is why I want to breathe
on you he said that you may receive this great good that my will reign in you and give you back
all the goods and the rights which the divine will gave to the creation of man so it's not time for
the general Pentecost to happen yet so what he does is he wants Louisa to have it personally
and any individual who will enter the divine will he wants them to have it personally
and gradually if enough people have the divine will personally the holy spirit can descend
in other words it's the red carpet idea again I want to give you also john 20 22 and 23
and that is that Jesus spent three and a half years training the disciples and then they all
failed him and it was only when he breathed on them after the resurrection that they came alive
spiritually that's john 20 22 and 23 and the way that is described in john's gospel is in imitation
of Genesis two seven that in the beginning man was created and then came alive with the breath of
God and here the church was created what came alive only with the breath of God and that's why
Pentecost is considered the birthday of the church and the Lord is really looking forward to it
as he was saying this drawing near me he breathed it on me he looked at me he clashed me and he
disappeared from me okay so that's the gift he wants to give to the whole church but the world
isn't ready yet.